at an air force base in the south of
taiwan
fighter jets practice for an incursion
towards the island
by military planes from nearby mainland
china
jets have been scrambling for real more
often as china has stepped up its
military patrols
most recently last weekend it seems to
be beijing's reminder that it will
always regard taiwan as part of china
and it's prepared to take it back by
force if necessary
we make no promise to renounce the use
of force and reserve the option to use
all necessary measures our position has
been consistent
and will not change taiwan's president
saying when
inspecting her military's preparedness
says the island is ready for any
aggression
from last year our radar stations have
detected incursions by nearly 2 000
chinese military aircraft in over 400
military vessels
we drove them away in a timely manner
and secured our maritime and airspace
increased activity across the taiwan
strait comes as the u.s
conducts a so-called freedom of
navigation exercise
sending an aircraft carrier group into
the nearby
south china sea angering beijing which
regards it
as largely its own during the recent
turbulent years of the trump
administration
taiwan has often been caught in the
middle of strained relations between
china and the us and the new biden
administration
might not mean an end to that turbulence
i also believe that
president trump was right in taking a
tougher approach
to china i disagree very much with
uh the way that he went about it in a
number of areas but the basic principle
was the right one the major players in
east asia geopolitics
are embarking on a new era but bringing
with them
the same tensions from the last one rob
mcbride al jazeera